so much thanks to Hillsdale College
thanks to my Bell for inviting me mostly
thank you all for coming could see
everything alright good
so historians tell stories probably more
than anything else is what they do and
the thing about the stories historians
tell is they tend to try to make the
past make sense have some order have
some direction have some purpose a whole
lot more order direction and purpose
than it had for anybody living through
history at the time maybe even history
itself and one of the things about
stories as stories have beginnings in
the history of the Russian Revolution
could be started in a lot of different
places but I'm gonna start in a
particularly dramatic place maybe some
would say really the beginning of the
Russian Revolution this first massive
social political upheaval the first one
in Russian history anything like it in
modern Russian history which is in 1905
it began on a cold Sunday in January in
the capital of the Russian Empire st.
Petersburg with a huge March by
thousands of workers and their families
toward the Winter Palace
carrying a petition for the Tsar for
nicholas ii their main complaints you
can see some of these words from the
actual petition itself they complained
about despotism they complained about
arbitrary power they complained about
their suffering and their lack of rights
they already had this language of rights
and they didn't blame the Tsar they
blame bureaucrats and capitalist
exploiters and their main demand and
this speaks just to what Matt Bell was
just saying their main demand was
basically to be treated as human beings
and they used the word human rights long
before we're used to thinking of it part
of politics and what did this mean human
rights to them you can see some of the
language it meant specifically freedom
and viability of the person freedom of
speech impressed s' of assembly of
conscience and the practice of religion
that's from the petition it also meant a
constitutional and electoral political
system
it meant suffer universal
secret and equal suffrage it meant
legalization of all forms of Association
including trade unions managers unions
the right of strike and state
intervention to improve working and
living conditions and reduce poverty as
they said until poverty is reduced how
can we live like human beings now I
don't need to tell you when you look at
that list of demands and look at that
vocabulary clearly the Russian
Revolution
if the 1905 didn't start in 1905 that
language draws deeply on Russian
traditions I wouldn't have to I could
tell you a whole history of those ideas
in Russia but obviously on Western ideas
as well however while this is already a
set of ideas that play in Russia with
deep roots in European and American
history they were very aware of the
American Revolution and its principles
there was another opposing history of
ideas that articulated by the Russian
monarchy which called itself an
autocracy and and its many supporters
this was a tradition of course
exemplified by bizarre the last Tsar he
didn't know it yet but the Tsar who
ruled in 1905 Nicholas the second
there's a lot of things I could tell you
about him but the one is very telling
the very moment he came to the throne
which was in 1894 after his father died
he invited representatives of society to
come and meet with him and he warned
them they're all standing there
representing various social classes and
groups and he said I know that there are
people among you who were talking about
the rights of citizens who were talking
about the rights of democratic
participation through elections in
government and I want to tell you their
senseless dreams senseless dreams you
can see they all went away with their
tails between their legs and did a lot
of thinking after that and in fact
throughout Nicholas the seconds reign he
articulated a political ideology that
reflected these sorts of ideas he
believed these were deeply rooted in
Russian tradition
which is to summarize basically a view
of the political order as based on a
mystical bond of love between the ruler
and his people which formal institutions
got in the way of that laws got in the
way of nothing should stand between this
sort of almost mystical bond you can see
this image up here is Nikolas sending
off troops to the russo-japanese war
another catastrophe that often sparked
revolution and he was full of emotion
every time he did this when people they
got down on their knees and there was a
real sense of see my people love me why
do I need a parliament why do we need
elections but back to the streets of
1905 January 9th on the Russian calendar
13 days behind the European calendar
this procession to the Tsar which I
mentioned which one might say
potentially could fit his model of the
people coming to to speak to him
although the demands didn't sound like
his ideology this ended when troops met
the marchers in various parts of the
city and fired on them killing hundreds
wounding many more this day January 9th
1905 became known as Bloody Sunday and
it sparked a revolution protest meetings
for months marches for months
demonstrations strikes by everybody
students were on strike professors were
on strike not to mention workers
proliferation of civic organizations and
it used to be to get have an
organization a trade union a society a
club you had to ask the government for
permission in 1905 people said why let's
just do it
so they by direct action created all
sorts of organizations without
permission
special organizations electoral bodies
representing workers in in cities like
sort of worker Parliament's were formed
and they called them councils and the
Russian word for counsel is Soviet
that's where we get the Russian word
Soviet as became the Soviet Union they
also had a free press not because there
what there had been censorship they
simply decided to print whatever they
want say whatever they want without
asking permission this was sort of a
taneous movement of creating liberty on
the streets right from below and even
peasants began to get involved
especially trying to get more land for
their lives to restore some sort of
peace and legitimacy to his government
nicholas ii issued a manifesto in
October 1905 literally on October 17th
that's a picture of what happens when he
issues this manifesto his minister said
you've really got to do this later he
said I'm sorry I listened to them but
this was a joyous moment for this
society he promised a parliament it's
called to be called the Duma still
called the Duma or again after communism
to represent all classes of the
population that could have the power to
approve or reject laws supervise the
legality of everything the government
did with the exception of the Tsar he
could still do what he wanted and as you
see these lines from the quote granting
to the population so he's he's adopting
this language the unshakeable
foundations of civic civil freedom based
on the principles of genuine and
viability of the person and freedom of
conscience speech assembly an
association familiar language to all of
us now was officially adopted by the
Tsar it had a long history of welling up
in Russia this was as this picture
suggests welcomed with people flew
poured into the streets these days
became known as the days of freedom in
Russian history but also people were
making more demands they were still
demonstrations there were still strikes
partly because people didn't trust
Nicholas given everything he had said
before this didn't sound like him but
also because they thought this is a good
start let's go even further now the
years that followed 1906 2fort until the
war were very complicated and again I'm
a lot one could tell complicated in part
because Nicholas started taking away
some of the things he agreed to in the
October manifesto
the most common way historians talk
about those years after the 1905
revolution before World War one and the
Russian 1917 revolution is what
historians like to call the optimist
pessimist
that's what we often teach in classrooms
to help capture what the basic choices
were and in a nutshell this was
basically was Russia as a result of the
changes of 1905 moving toward becoming a
normal civil society with degrees of
participation and freedom that was
solving some of people's discontent and
there's lots of evidence that it was or
was Russia hurdling inescapably towards
some new crisis some revolution possibly
even without the war and there's plenty
of evidence that it was part of the
argument for optimists is give Russia
enough time the Prime Minister even said
that and Russia will become a normal
society if we can avoid a war and war is
what's said to have short-circuited that
progress one could debate one way or the
other about this what's important of
course is that the war did come and
hence we can't know what would have
happened without world war one there is
Nicholas and Alexandra standing on the
balcony of the Winter Palace on 20th
July 1914 on the Russian calendar the
day that war was started that Russia
entered the war and the square is full
of people singing god save the Tsar
another moving moment for him this war
was a catastrophe it Russia suffered
unparalleled human losses a
disintegrating economy with a lack of
food in the cities became the most
symbolic an aggravating sign hence
famous for long bread lines clearly the
war shaped what happened in 1917 though
it's worth saying no one expected the
1917 revolution not bizarre not Lenin
not other socialists not people in the
streets it happened unexpectedly though
that's something you're going to hear
about it in a moment it began with
strikes and protests over food shortages
this was in late February 1917 together
with a gigantic march of women on
International Women's Day March 8 on our
calendar late February on theirs march
of women of which many were demanding
bread the Czar made the same mistake he
made once before he said in this time of
war we can't have people out on the
streets demonstrating send the troops
out and tell him to go home and if they
don't go home
shoot them he's at the front at this
point and he thinks that you know this
is important they go out on the troops
they go out into the streets there are
lots of people there they won't go home
so the troops shoot and then they go
back to their barracks and the people go
back to their homes and everything
changes this isn't 1905 the people go
back out under the streets and say
forget it let them shoot us again we are
not giving up we've suffered too much
we've waited too long but the troops who
go back to the garrison and they talk
about it
say we can't shoot at our people and
they come out on the street with red
ribbons tied to their bayonets they're
handing their guns to everybody this
mutiny is what ultimately led the Czar's
generals his ministers to say you need a
bigger concession than last time
this time you need to abdicate it's the
only way no one believes you anymore and
he does he advocates in favor of his
brother and his brother said that's the
last thing in the world I would want is
to be Tsar in this part in this crisis
so one might say no one no one takes
picks up picks up the dropped crown what
you get instead are two bodies neither
of which have any what good legitimacy
one is a few members of the of the
parliament the Duma decide to form a
provisional government they call a
provisional because they didn't nobody
elected them you see their pictures
that's the Cabinet of Ministers
meanwhile workers create soviets again
joined by soldiers so they're called
worker and soldier soviets later as
peasants actually send delegates to a
national body and that you see them at
the bottom these two bodies are
constantly competing and coexisting it
was known as dual power wasn't sure who
was actually in charge that seven months
that followed from February to October
was a series of political crises mostly
over the war which was still going on
and still terrible mostly over the
economic problems the economy the lack
of food people are still wanting bread
and
one of the signs of how frustrated
people were here you see one of the many
many demonstrations oh it says on the
banner it says this is in June it says
peace to the whole world all power to
the people all land to the people and
then on the right it says down with the
capitalist ministers it was assumed
they're all bourgeoisie and capitalists
that's what was always said that became
like an insult to just use those words
they were mostly liberals some of them
were even one of them was even a history
professor bourgeois capitalists what can
I say one of the signs of how frustrated
people were getting by October is that
in those Soviets that you saw the
picture of which were constantly sending
new delegates and having new elections
and they elected they tended to choose a
bunch of intellectuals as their leaders
but they voted them and they knew which
party by September it was decided in
most Soviets around the country by
election to choose Bolsheviks to run the
place to be heads representing the
Soviets people were actually voting for
Bolsheviks why they didn't read Lenin
what they knew was the Bolsheviks had
the best slogan around and they were
frustrated and the slogan you've
probably heard was peace you see part of
it in that banner piece in other words
let's get us out of this war bread
provide us food solve the problem of the
disintegrating economy land you see that
also slogan there in other words let the
peasants have more land actually let
them take all the land they work they're
working it might as well own it and this
really key idea all power to the Soviets
in other words let's get rid of dual
power let's just have the Soviets the
elected bodies of workers peasants and
soldiers be the new government and it's
really important to know and remember
that when the Bolsheviks Trotsky and
Lenin and others organized an armed
seizure of power and it was it's been
called a coup d'etat and in effect it it
was they made it clear they're not
seizing power for the Bolshevik Party
they would have never gotten anywhere if
they said that they said this is on
November 7th on the run our calendar
October 25th on theirs they said the
revolution that they were making was for
Soviet power and those Soviets included
represents of all the lot sort of
liberal and mostly left-wing socialist
parties all right that's the story
that's all you need right that's the
typical history story it's all I think
I've told it correctly that's history as
offense but I want to go deeper into the
spirit of the time into people's
experience this is obviously very
difficult we can't go back we can't be
there I wasn't there
I'm too I'm old but not that old you
know to find out we I want my goal is to
how can we hear their voices and get
some sense of what they were saying and
feeling and fortunately revolutions
everybody's observed before are like
Bacchanalia zuv words people just can't
stop talking and fortunately some of
that talk ends up in newspapers or
memoirs which is what I can read so now
I want to back up again back to 1905 to
see if we can go deeper under the skin
of what's happening one of the
best-known Russian newspapers in 1905
Moscow paper called the Russian word
ruski Slovo which identified itself as
the people's paper it reflected the the
experience of as they like to say the
man on the street here's how they
describe the mood right after Bloody
Sunday when the country it's not Bloody
Sunday it's that upheaval that I've
described that sort of creating freedom
in everyday life and you see some of the
words it's the dawn of a new life the
country standing on the eve of its
liberation on the boundary between
impenetrable darkness and a bright
luminous and spacious future a historic
time of renewal rebirth Renaissance this
is sort of the language that they're
using now this may sound totally
overwrought over the top hyperbolic and
it was because that's actually what
revolutions tend to sound like to send a
feel like after the October manifesto
the sense of history happening in a very
exciting way was felt even more strongly
again some lines from some of the
newspapers just right after October and
note some of this
today begins a new life they keep using
that word Russian history has gone on to
a new path throughout the centuries of
Russia's servile existence we've never
known a stronger happier moment newness
was all over this thing
people said talked about new life a new
beginning a time of creating even new
people were being born in the midst of
all that with a renewed spirit and at
the heart and soul of these feelings you
can see is the idea of freedom probably
the most widely spoken word at the time
and in fact freedom and this is
important to understand for Russians in
1905 and again in 1917 sort of worked
for all the other work words it combined
a lot of things in one word Russia and
more words from the time one columnist
declared was finally joining the common
family of bold people's advancing toward
freedom and happiness the road would not
be easy they said this was a fight to
death between two great giants the new
life with its freedom and freshness and
the old one decrepit and all this is a
quote decrepit and ulcerous but still
able to bite sharply in its final
convulsions this was the a historic
battle between darkness and light
between freedom and slavery this is how
people felt about these events and most
said but we know how it's good in
because good always wins
freedom will always win freedom of
thought speech person indeed they like
to say liberty equality fraternity they
know where that came from the French
Revolution they're all talking in this
because they feel this isn't just Russia
this is part of a universal human
struggle for freedom and happiness now
this new and miraculous this freedom was
understood in very practical terms to be
free you need a proper representative
government you need free speech and
assembly you need the rule of law you
need ending poverty you need avoiding
war remember they were also at war again
this is 1905 but it was also perhaps
even more freedom was understood as some
spiritual as something emotional it was
a treasure these are their words bought
with blood and tears it was a star it
was one of my favorite metaphors a star
glimpsed through the Narron narrow
prison window of oppression they thought
they feel like they're living in a
prison and they can look out and see
that star that's what freedom is it's a
comet it's a meteor it's rays of light
it's burning flames it's fresh wine
they're just like constantly trying to
find what is the right word to capture
the spirit of what this represented and
then come the years after 1905 and
everybody agrees these were depressing
times beyond the actual conditions of
love what was happening because people
expected so much and got so relatively
little also society was full of problems
crime and violence and suicide was very
widespread and whenever anybody talked
about what's the public mood and they
loved talking about the public mood in
newspapers they always said it's dark
it's depressed
it's melancholy and one of the most
interesting ways to see the mood of this
of these years this is now 1906 to 1914
is New Year's Day editorials or essays
New Year's is New Year's Day is a great
time you think about what has passed you
think about what's to come it's it's the
classic moment to think about the future
and also the sort of passage of time and
there are just here's just some quotes
from some of the New Year's Day
editorials in these years before the war
and after 1905 the old has been
destroyed but there's no new yet time
has shattered the foundations for hope
how many times has the specter of
happiness deceived us they and they
there's this New Year's greeting when
you meet somebody on the street on New
Year's Day you say you this phrase that
you can that you can see somewhere there
well anyway for a new year for new
happiness this was always the phrase
that's how you greet somebody and
editorialists commented that was nice
you wished it last year we didn't get it
it's just wishes because as one writer
said who happened to be a psychiatrist
to reality doesn't bring happiness and
you can see more quotes like this all
they get it was said is bitterness and
disillusionment and that is probably the
captures the mood in these years of yeah
progress but very disappointing no sense
of happiness or freedom then comes World
War one which surprisingly is great it
feels good yes we're gonna fight against
the Kaiser and the Kaiser hates freedom
he also hates Russians and even though
he's a relative but they didn't worry
about that
you know Germany it was seen this is
just like the worst of Russia it's not a
free country therefore if we're fighting
against Germany we're must be fighting
for freedom or as you see in this world
war one poster for truth and justice
Pravda you all know the word Pravda from
the used to be the Communist Party
newspaper prompt is a word that means
both truth and justice it's a very
special type of truth and frankly people
were full of hope you can see this quote
even a year into the war full of hope of
renewal of salvation to the country of
people coming together but it doesn't
last the war gets worse and worse and
that hope yet again is shattered more
bitterness more disillusionment and the
real troubling thing is however dark
things were during world war as the war
went on however frustrated people were
they it wasn't going to be reported in
the press the way it had been in the
years before nobody's talking about how
depressed people are there don't matter
how happy everybody is because so they
had the seething frustration had to be
out of sight because of wartime
censorship and then comes 1917 right
after the Tsar's overthrown yet again if
they declare these to be the days of
freedom they love that phrase and people
acted on the streets just like they did
after the October manifesto they acted
like this was some sort of religious
holiday like some sort of miracle had
just happened poured into the streets
people are embracing each other they're
kissing
strangers here's from a memoir by a
writer viktor shklovsky is his name he
said it was just like Easter a joyous
naive disorderly Carnival Paradise or an
eighteen year old woman who was working
in a Moscow Factory in 1917 also
recalled this time she said the
revolution felt like seemed like a
wonderful holiday we were happy
not that they're getting happiness
through the revolution that
revolutionary moment felt how like
happiness we felt like adults for the
first time for the first time we felt
completely free indeed these were
Russians said at the time this was the
springtime of freedom and everybody is
talking in these terms some of these
quotes here on March 3rd the very day
after the Tsar abdicates a woman named
Maria up across Gaia she's a physician
described her sense of the moment in
simple words she said Russia has
suddenly turned a new page in her
history and inscribed on it
freedom exactly like people were saying
in 1905 newspapers tried and they never
could to capture the mood of what was
happening of history as it was
experienced right then at that moment
here's a quote from a kopeck means a
penny kopeck newspaper so very cheap
popular paper and part of the quote is
up here but you have to hear it it's
just it's just amazing this is typical
of how people talk to the time the
dazzling Sun appear this is like four
days after the Tsar has abdicated foul
mists were dispersed great Russia
stirred the long-suffering people arose
the nightmare yoke fell freedom and
Happiness forward hoorah hoorah hoorah
with a thunderous roar the thousand
voice cry of the people cheer a student
orator from end to end a carried excited
voices every face is tense gestures bold
and free people admire the red flags
fluttering above their heads they look
around they gather in large crowds share
impressions of the new and the
unexpected people embrace kiss
congratulate one another throw
themselves greedily at every
proclamation they read loudly abrupt
agitated Li from mouth to mouth passes
the long-awaited joyous news freedom
freedom freedom tears glisten in the
eyes of many uncontainable wild joy you
can read the papers at the time and
you'll see similar essays constantly
springtime of resurrection springtime of
renewal springtime of freedom these are
the phrases you'd hear the Russian
Revolution appeared so unexpectedly like
at once said like oxygen to a dying man
and I could quote many many articles
like that a great joy a sacred time a
time of resurrection short phrases
capital letters on every word
exclamation points all seem to be needed
to express the sense of what hope
because nothing much had happened except
the Tsar had fallen and troops didn't
fight some new government they knew
nothing about had taken power hope is
what's being articulated here for
freedom you can hear all the religious
language it's it was everywhere even on
people who thought of themselves as
Marxist used it these are postcards
Easter of 1917 people are handing out
postcards it's a popular thing with
Easter greetings happens to be right
after in in April and these combine all
the politics it's like all mushed up
here you've got a worker and a soldier
right that's the Soviet on the one on
the left behind is a Rising Sun with the
words Christ is risen that's the
greeting on Easter you say to people
Christ is risen and people greet you
back saying verily he has risen that's
part of this thing and below on a big
red Easter egg it's a red Easter egg of
course long live the Republic or on the
other side same thing Christ has written
the freedom of Russia this is how people
thought and there was a deeply spiritual
sacred quality of all this meanwhile
nicholas ii has a very different mood at
this point though also deeply rooted in
religion in morality in ideas and
feelings he writes to hit letters he's
at the front still he writes it as diary
he writes in letters back
his wife in those days leading up to his
abdication but after all this chaos in
the streets and he wrote things like
it's a shame and a disgrace what is
going on especially that soldiers are
participating in those disorders it is
nothing but treachery cowardice and
deceit those are his words that people
are telling him he oughta advocate his
own generals are saying he should
advocate nothing but treachery cowardice
and deceit and after he came down from
power after he was held in arrest under
arrest and under house arrest he
constantly kept looking around and
saying freedom is a scary thing be
careful because freedom without order is
catastrophe freedom without morality is
catastrophe without moral responsibility
the country is going to fall apart
people say it's one of the cliches that
Nicholas ii was stupid he was not stupid
and he was not preoccupied just with his
wife and his son he had a very clear
ideological vision it was different than
what was unfolding in the streets again
freedom was the dominant motif
everybody's talking about freedom and
what's interesting is you can hear in
this language freedom as it was
understood was ubiquitous but it was
also ambiguous what did it mean so many
things it stood for everything and in a
weird way
Russians were participating in a sort of
worldwide debate about what is freedom
and I'm conscious that this is at
Hillsdale College where I'm talking
about this where among places colleges
in the country it is a particular
important theme here Russians were aware
of a lot of the debates and they were
take they were arguing about it partly
it's the debate over negative freedom or
Liberty and positive freedom as it
happens there are two words in Russian
for this is freedom Liberty from
constraints is freedom or Liberty
emancipating justice does it free you
but create conditions that are just it's
freedom about freeing individuals to
pursue happiness or is it about freedom
as the guarantee of happiness
the actual conditions that ensure people
are happy is it about individual or
inner freedom is it about freedom
realized in a new society now political
philosophers especially those who
studied the Russian Revolution but also
more broadly in particular I'm thinking
of the great historian of Russia and
political philosopher Azad isaiah berlin
berlin warned very clearly not always
about the Russian Revolution about
confusing what he called Liberty with
her sisters equality and fraternity as
in the slogan of the French Revolution
those are her sisters they're not the
same as Liberty he said it's a very
dangerous mistake he wrote this in his
essay some of you know two concepts of
Liberty Liberty from 1958 to conflate
the freedom that emancipates the
individual from external control that
allows an active life and pursuit of
freedom and freedom that itself promotes
happiness by changing society for the
better however whatever you feel about
the the the theoretical nature of those
definitions for better or worse in the
history of most revolutions in the world
this conflation of Liberty and her
sisters is exactly what people were
doing all the time whether it was good
or not this is how they understood this
we see this very strongly in 1917 people
kept insisting freedom could not exist
without changing society without greater
equality without fraternity to use those
phrase without her sisters this meant
freedom meant you've got to solve the
material problems how could people be
free they kept saying if we're soldiers
being sent off to war to die against
their will
how can you be free if you're standing
in bread lines and there's not enough
food how can you be free when you can't
afford things because of the terrible
inflation how could you be free if
you're a peasant and don't control the
land you work on but have to pay
somebody rent for it how can you be free
if you don't have education to
understand what freedom is for many I
would say most at least lower-class
Russians workers soldiers peasants the
vast majority of the population this
wasn't confused
conflating liberty and her sisters they
were sisters they depended on one
another they were bonded freedom
depended on all those things in
particular as in the Bolshevik slogan
peace bread and land that was what
freedom meant now I know that in the
course of the seminar you we will be
talking about many of the brutalities in
the name of freedom in the name of
justice in the name of fraternity that
was the result of the Bolshevik
Revolution Matt mentioned some of those
this includes the execution of nicholas
ii not just him his family his servants
his children everybody it includes
enormous amount of repressions against
anybody declared to be an enemy of the
revolution an enemy of the people
terror and Russians were very happy to
use the word terror and frankly even
many ordinary Russians began to think
that what they fought for was not being
realized
to give just one example of this they
were kur all we know is his name is f
Petrof we don't even know his first name
he wrote to the head of the Soviet
government in January of 1918 so this is
very early the worst is yet to come
he wrote to the Soviet government and
after the closing of an elected body
called the Constituent Assembly there'd
been a natural national election all the
parties got although all the socialist
parties got to run votes were tallied it
was a very fair election probably the
first really truly fair Universe
election in Russia only the bourgeoisie
was left out but that was they were
happy about that but guess what the
Bolsheviks lost the socialist
revolutionary party a different party
won so the Bolsheviks sent in troops and
said thank you
history's moved on you're done and
people took to the streets and protested
this outraged a lot of people and you
get statements like this one how long
this is written by a worker to the
Bolshevik government how long are you
aggressors to going to go on crucifying
freedom you're imposters you imposters
have the nerve to call yourselves a
worker peasant government you're selling
out and betraying
you're killing off everything holy
you're against popular power get out of
here and go back to where you came from
he doesn't say where that is we demand
you give us back the Constituent
Assembly all power must belong to the
people remember that's what the
Revolution was all power to the people
to the Soviets we don't trust any party
members down with all the parties long
live the Constituent Assembly eternal
memory to the memory to the fallen and
curses on the tyrants whoever they are
now we know how things turned out much
worse than even Petrov could have
imagined and in that in light of how
things turned out it's very easy to
forget or dismiss is sort of
historically moot because it turned out
differently the ideas and emotions that
I have been describing the spirit of the
Russian Revolution especially the belief
in the possibility of a new beginning
that so many people talked about
considering frankly how things turned
out it's very easy to just be
pessimistic about history conclude that
the only smart people understand that
existence is never gonna turn out happy
existence is basically a melancholy
affair that recognizes that we will long
for freedom and will long for justice
and will long for happiness just
illusions in all to human world that's
the easy answer and maybe even the right
answer but I think the Russian
Revolution at its best authors account a
counter argument the argument of the
willingness of so many people they knew
what they were up against to go out into
the streets in 1905 and 1917 to create
new institutions to talk in a language
you've heard about thinking maybe
history could go in a different way
maybe the really new is possible and one
might say well they were just wrong and
so I want to conclude in a very in a
weird way which is to say there are
philosophers important ones lots of them
who actually know what happened in the
Russian Revolution they these are I'm
thinking of three in particular who
studied the Russian Revolution who were
very distressed by its outcome in fact
they're writing after world war two they
know how bad his
he can be how many disappointments and
terrors the 20th century brought all
three were refugees from Nazi Germany to
made it to America one had to commit
suicide because he was captured and held
while trying to leave for America there
three of them very briefly one is this
man Ernst block after he came to the
United States from Nazi Germany he wrote
a three-volume gigantic study with a
very simple title the principle of hope
is an absolutely unreadable gigantic
thing that looks at every aspect of
anything that's happened anywhere in
every culture in the world to show one
thing human beings have an impulse
toward not only hope but actually toward
him believing the world could be
different and here's one line from an
interview we actually gave in 1964
saying friends the ocean of possibility
is much greater than our customary land
of reality that the possible is greater
than we can imagine or somebody who
probably will know Hana our it wrote an
essay very famous in 1961 it was
published called
on the meanings of freedom and she says
something very similar and I think that
also speaks to the Russian case freedom
is a miracle that is something which
could not be expected you heard how
often the Russian Revolution was
unexpected they said that in fact she
said every new beginning in human
history breaks into the world as an
infinite in probability and yet it is
precisely this infinitely improbable
which actually constitutes the very
texture of everything we call real
because our very existence of the
humanity of our planet is as she said
based on a chain of miracles the
likelihood we even exist as a miracle
therefore it's right she said it's the
most natural and realistic thing for
humans to her words look for the
unforeseeable and unpredictable to be
prepared for and expect miracles in the
political realm even though the scales
are weighted in favor of disaster
freedom it seems to me she's saying very
much thinking I think could be applied
to the Russian Revolution freedom is not
so much that goal
that you're trying to achieve it is
mostly the act of human will that dares
to chance against the odds that you can
have a different future or to quote her
directly that's my interpretation over
to quote her directly the freedom to
call something into being which did not
exist before which was not given not
even as an object of cognition or
imagination is the essence of human
freedom sorry that's not on the
PowerPoint and finally the last one man
named Walter Benjamin a friend of blah a
friend of Hannah Arendt she played a key
role he's the one who committed suicide
in promoting his work in the United
States
in 1940 which is the year he tried to
flee Europe and had failed he liked
block actually a Marxist a disillusioned
Marxist offered a very interesting
variation but also I think speaks and
this will be my conclusion to the
Russian Revolution one of the most
famous lines in Marxism whole books have
been written about this one phrase you
can see it at the top is that a
revolution is humanity's leap from the
kingdom of necessity to the kingdom of
freedom there's a very fat book all
about what those words mean voltar
Benjamin did something really
interesting to this he changed it a
little bit even though he was writing as
a Marxist revolution he said is a leap
in the open air of history a leap that
offers humanity the chance these are his
words to blast open the continuum of
history to grass splinters and flashes
of what he called messianic time which
is time open to the future this is a
very important difference for Marx and
angles it's all about the destination
the utopian kingdom of freedom and we
know this vision the kingdom of freedom
which is where human will will dominate
everything there'll be no necessity can
be a very potentially dangerous faith
when a powerful group of people believes
that that end is so good that any means
no matter how brutal are not only
justified but in noble by that great and
Benjamin emphasized the leap is the
important part of thinking about
revolution he knew the odds like our
enta that are infinitely small they're
just splinter
he says a possibility for salvation for
a miracle but it's the most telling mark
of humanity at its best when humans
tried to leap to hope to try to turn the
wheel of history the meaning of the word
revolution we know how they landed they
leave they left they landed badly what
I'm trying to suggest here though the
void through the voices of Russians
experiencing their history through the
voices of later philosophers who knew
very well how badly history could go
that there's something useful and
valuable for understanding history for
understanding the revolution maybe even
for thinking about our own lives and our
own times to ponder those moments like
1917 and 1905 when Russians dared to
leap in the open air of possibility or
in Hana Ourense line to try to call
something into being that did not exist
before thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
questions please raise your hand and the
microphone will be brought to you hello
I'm from Russian heritage and I know
that Christmas and New Year's are
special times I'm kind of surprised that
all of these things happened on these
days when they're supposed to have been
Christian good holidays because the
church was supposedly very important so
I'd like to know why
well they didn't happen precisely on
those days so of course their different
calendar because where Christmas is New
Year's for a while so no actual big
events happened on exactly those days
but they embraced them as times to think
especially New Year's which was that's
when you get the Christmas tree it's
called a New Year's tree actually that
was a time everybody thought about what
was happening and it's really
interesting I didn't read these things
what people were saying in New Year's
1917 because they were sounding just
like everybody else it's like I don't
think it's gonna go well history's never
changing nothing will ever be different
that's like a month before the
Revolution Easter is the biggest holiday
in Russia and Easter hell like this is
the greatest Easter we've ever had even
people who weren't that religious even
Jews were going on in the streets saying
it feels like Easter that Gaia quoted
shklovsky he was Jewish it's like it's
Easter you know because Easter is the
time of Hope of Resurrection of
salvation
it became enormous ly important so it
was embedded in the excitement of the
time very much so and then of course it
was banned as holiday maybe for good
reason thank you
I'm a Russian immigrant so I'm immensely
grateful that an institution such as
Hillsdale College has gathered such a
huge crowd to study such an important
event many Russians don't no longer
think about it and ponder the
significant lessons of it but you are a
American historian who specializes in
this particular subject and I have a
question for you Americans love happy
endings Russians are very content being
living to show the world how not to live
but since you are an American historian
my question is if you were to write a
happy ending to the Russian Revolution
what would it have been thank you so
Russians love happy endings so much as
you know that the Russian word for a
happy ending in movies is happy ending
it's actually it's it's they understand
that this is an idea that is so American
that Havana they call is spoken in
English there's no Russian equivalent
you know you probably all heard the the
line tchau tchau and lie the head of
China somebody asked you know what's
your judgement of the outcome of the
French Revolution and he said too soon
to tell
and it's a great line but it actually he
was apparently talking about 1967 or 68
in the streets and it was not about
their actual Russian French Revolution
but I think it's a perfect insight and
it is really too soon to tell I mean so
no one expected 1917 to happen this
isn't gonna really directly answer your
question but it indirectly no one really
knew that it was coming
I mean Lenin you know was in exile
writing a long book because he thought
nothing was happening it was over the
Czar didn't see it coming otherwise he
would have acted differently same thing
with the October Revolution nobody saw
these things and the exact same thing
was true in the Soviet Union I mean I've
been going to the Soviet Union from 1983
the first time constantly since then and
have a lot of Soviet friends and I
remember going in a long walk it was in
20 no it was in 19 I don't know several
years before 1991 and that my friend was
saying who I'd known since the eighties
you know the Romanov dynasty lasted 300
years so of the Soviet Union there's not
a single reason to believe the Soviet
Union could fall apart
impossible won't happen and it did and
frankly political scientists all had mud
on their faces in the West cuz nobody
could could predict it so rather than
offer what would be the happy ending
that certainly it hasn't happened yet
and I don't personally think that Putin
represents the happy ending of getting
past communism the happy ending is what
people dreamed of the happy ending is
what they imagined a society that is
both personally free that has Liberty as
the Russians call it volume and has this
other freedoms laborda and all the
richness of freedom as a society that is
happy and just and with a relative
degree of equality or at least enough
prosperity for everyone that's what
they've been fighting for and frankly I
could I'm a historian of America Arata
American historian of Russian but I
would say though you can go back at
least to the 1790s to 1820s and see this
desire they never ever got it the happy
ending is fine
the unexpected just like Hannah Arendt's
said the absolutely the luck the odds
our infant is Mille the scales are
weighted against it but the happy ending
would be they would finally get what
they've been wanting for so long and
that's that's my vision whenever I go to
Russia I sit with my friends and we
drink a lot and talk about it could be
different maybe it ought to be different
maybe it will be thanks hello my name is
Vivian I'm from Richmond Indiana
I'm a certified gemologist and friend of
Hillsdale College Mike I think of what
happened in the jewelry industry back in
the early nineteen hundreds specifically
so much was happening in America that
time there the rise of New York City the
Art Nouveau things like films were
coming too for was was anything that was
happening in Western civilization and
specifically in the United States was
was if part of what these families in
Soviet or Russia or thinking of when
they were thinking of freedom and
liberty and justice were they seen it
happen here and think we can have that
so there's two sides of that one is
especially before 1917 when the press
was relatively free relatively there
were lots of articles about what life
was like in Europe what life was like in
the u.s. the thing that Russians noticed
mostly was it was a whole lot more
prosperous you know for the vast
majority of Russians they were frankly
quite poor and so that was the thing on
the one hand that they noticed is why do
we have to be so poor other societies
aren't this poor maybe if we didn't have
autocracy our economy could thrive in
the 1970s and 80s they said maybe if we
didn't have communism we wouldn't be so
for you know they also knew what life
was like in the West so yeah it
absolutely had that influence the other
side is this ideological one and you can
you know it's like all it's one of the
reasons I
I quoted so often from before the
Revolution from during the Revolution
that language is clearly shaped by
something other than just well it's it's
almost become part of Russian thinking
if you look at intellectuals most
Russians didn't know where a lot of it
came from but they knew the world
believed in freedom the world believed
in justice the world believed in the in
viability of the inviolability of the
person in electoral rights women's
suffrage was one of the things being
demanded in 1917 because they knew
didn't exist anywhere but they knew that
it was a demand around the world so
they're very aware of being part of this
sort of global but mostly Western
ideology of freedom and justice and
democratic participation all those words
democracy freedom justice of course had
Russian equivalents not democracy that
was they borrowed that from from the
Latin but they were very aware that they
what they were fighting for
hence liberty equality and fraternity
was deeply rooted in what others were
thinking and Russians had a tendency to
think these that's because their
universal truths they are as we might
say self-evident and I think they're
very aware in the early 19th century
intellectuals were very fond of the
American Revolution they liked it a lot
they followed these people I saw a
little Statute of Thomas Paine he was a
big favorite out there
they knew Thomas Jefferson they knew all
of this stuff also Rousseau in Voltaire
another so yeah this was Russia's not an
island it's happening it's connected to
the world and this shapes what people do
and still today I can't call on people
so she's the microphones I'm charge yeah
a tree callous fat did there were lots
of intellectuals behind the 9070
revolution all over Europe and Russia
apparently they did study what happened
in America or founding fathers the
Federalist Papers mm-hmm they didn't
make anything out of it they would do
what they did make anything out of it
they didn't learn from him not only dead
now in America we had burned
send us and the snowflakes that's our
future he would like to think so but I
don't so you know it's interesting when
ideas are present so let me use the
illustration of 1917 just to focus in on
what is a hundred years ago and that
group the provisional government right
that you that you saw a picture of some
of them were industrialists some of them
were lawyers some of them one of them
was a college professor he was the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs
they had these ideas yes they knew all
about the Western ideas they knew about
law they were very attached to the rule
of law
they knew what citizenship meant they
knew what democratic participation was
remember one of the first things they
did when they came to powers they said
finally Russia as it happens is allied
with the good people in this war just by
chance and we are allied with France
we're allied with England and well it
took till 1917 - they were allied to the
u.s. that can't we came late they were
very conscious of our ideas and also
being part of that world they tried to
create a very democratic little society
I mean if you look at what the
provisional government did these are
those people the intellectuals who know
these traditions they created all sorts
of freedoms they created extensive civil
rights they gave people rights to form
unions so many changes they even began
land reform they began to protect
workers rights this was progressive what
we would call progressive liberal
democracy and they were liberals they
call themselves liberals but they
believed individual liberty wasn't
enough yeah I don't was decided it was
just as well
did they make something of it they made
a lot of it they just had a couple of
big problems one was World War one there
wouldn't have been a revolution without
the war but the war is what doomed the
provisional government there was no way
they could realize this if they couldn't
get the country out of the war because
people believe not that the war itself
was bad though people were dying but the
war was destroying the economy and so
the circumstances were tear
and I am a historian so I only can tell
you what happened not what could have
happened but my whole talk in some ways
was full of that awareness that other
things could have happened they made a
few mistakes but basically they were
visionaries about what it could have
been like so there's another happy
ending
imagine if somehow America entered the
war in 1917 it ended two weeks later
because it was over the Germans said
forget it we're not fighting anymore and
the world was at peace in February or
March of 1917 and the provisional
government was this is totally
counterfactual that there's a happy
ending the provisional government stayed
in power the Soviet was there they were
like a interest group they were the
Liberals were very sensitive to social
needs of the population it could have
been that we would have had a republic
of Russia that was relatively free and
democratic and participating in all the
world of today would probably be a
member of the European Union by now so
they did try to make something of those
ideas circumstances were horrible
or as Hanan and said the scales are
tilted in favor of disaster that was not
a propitious time to create a really
democratic free society and that's
frankly a tragedy if it were me I would
say that was the result that should have
been allowed to play itself out seven
months it's not very long for that
liberal social democratic experiment so
yeah I give them credit for making an
attempt more question thank you so much
for coming you mentioned this idea of a
frustration among the Russian people
that constituted this rising spirit of
revolution do you think that this
inevitably led to violent political
change or do you think that there's
something that perhaps tsar nicholas ii
could have done to mitigate or channeled
that into a more peaceable form of
political change in russia and if so
what would that have been yeah well so
now it's getting personal because I've
written a lot about it about nicholas ii
and i've read everything he's ever
written and I've delved into his life he
was not stupid but he made some very
stupid mistakes so I think in 1905 he
could have agreed to continue what he
had promised
but he didn't because he had this
ideology he couldn't get out of so he
made a mistake then he made a mistake in
1917 when simply saying once again go
into the tell people to go home
he didn't understand to be sure he was
getting very bad advice from his wife
among others who understood even less
and you know it was a real it was
another mistake I mean he had really he
had made so many errors it's not
surprising how it ended the violence
though frankly the provisional
government could have tried to get out
of the war I don't think they could have
gotten out of the war it's too hard they
were lied with with countries so things
had become so angry people were so
frustrated by the time the provisional
government fell that the only way to
have avoided violence at that point is
for the other side let's call them the
other side right the liberals the
monarchists the United States who sent
troops to help out the white so-called
white side if they just said well we're
not particularly fond of Lenin but you
know every country should have be Celt
have you know the right to determine its
own face fate the sort of wilsonian idea
right just let them go their own way but
of course this was the really the
beginnings of what became the great
combat and of course fear of Bolshevism
who had already been rising so no the
country armed and helped the white army
there was a civil war and to be sure the
Bolsheviks were not against fighting a
civil war they thought in the the fires
of this righteous battle society would
be better they were very good at
justifying violence as virtue the whites
just said we got to do it because these
are evil people violence itself is in
virtue just our causes Bolsheviks
actually made the argument that they
were that the the killing itself became
virtuous so I think there was just too
many conditions that led to the violent
outcome that said in 1921 history turned
again they created a new policy they
started allowing modest capitalism they
gave people a lot more freedoms the
early 20s it seems like a whole other
possibility and the violence was over
until Stalin
and then it all starts again in a very
different way I actually don't think
there's anything inevitable about once
it was settled in 1921 that one had to
have the violence of Stalinism nothing
is inevitable each case has its own
contingents in shape unfortunately huh
no that's right scales are tilted in
favor of disaster and that's and
Russians what might say are unlucky
things kept going wrong
[Applause]